don't make me that asshole Amanda don't
make me that asshole
don't make me that asshole that doesn't
recommend break it Ralph - hey okay okay
if you got kids they'll probably like
this fine if you saw the trailer for
this movie and you're like that looks
like a lot of fun I laughed at the
trailer I had a good time you'll
probably like this fine if you're
looking for something on par with like a
lot of the really surprisingly really
good Disney stuff that's been coming out
lately and by lately I mean like the
past five six years and Pixar material
and so forth saying up the standards man
to just say okay this has a very good
message this has a very good you know
kind of idea behind it honestly if I was
like a producer or somebody at Disney
and somebody told me this idea I think
it's a good idea um but it just doesn't
flow man it doesn't connect from one
thing to next and I just I it wasn't
grabbing me I just wasn't feeling it um
I feel so I feel so dirty saying that
because it's wreck-it Ralph and I and I
really liked the first film and I
thought it was cute and nice and and had
a good moral and that the sequel just
did did not live up to the expectation
that I felt a good movie like that
deserved I mean like like a really good
follow-up but it's not it's not awful
it's not a terrible film it's not even
really that bad like I said for a kid's
film about a little video game character
it goes into the internet it's fine but
before the adults and Disney snobs like
me that really really sort of put them
on a pedestal and really expect them to
meet those expectations and really
really set the standards high I mean you
could argue that's not fair but Disney
is like they really do set the standards
on so many things and
and wreck-it Ralph kinda did too in some
respects so so let's talk about it the
set up I think a lot of you probably
know you watch the trailer
it's a Ralph and vanellope go into the
Internet her game is going to be turned
off unless they can get this new part on
eBay or as he calls an e boy or it comes
a bunch of different names so they have
to go get the part
somehow come up with money to pay for
this part because they put like a
ridiculous amount of money on it to win
it and they find all sorts of various
ways they can make that money online
honestly if it was this easy like a lot
of other people would have done it but I
guess I guess it kind of makes sense
because they kind of stumble into it
they and this is part of the problem
okay so they go to something called buzz
tube and it sort of ties into all the
things that like our big memes and sort
of these funny little videos and stuff
like that and it's one of those things
where it's like but they can't say
BuzzFeed and they can't say YouTube even
though they're in the movie they're like
in the background there they are they
they can't really connect it to that
Matt that's part of the problem that
that's a very small part so so they have
to get the money to get this part to
save her game Penelope's game but then
that's kind of abandoned uh that's kind
of not a thing anymore and they they
just kind of forget about it and I don't
even really forget about just something
else kind of catches their interest and
then that becomes the story and that's
one of the major problems of this is
that it just kind of with the first film
you get it he's sick of doing the same
thing over and over he said could being
the bad guy and I even do the same thing
over and over it just said could be in
the bad guy and so he wants to be the
hero and everyone can tend to fight with
that so he has to go and you know get
something that recognizes him
a hero and he comes across this goes
into a different realm and comes across
this little kid they be friends and even
though he doesn't become the hero in the
way he thought he becomes a hero in a
different way to this kid and in the
movie he still has the little metal you
know the little sugar cookie medal and
it's very cute um everyone can identify
with that this starts off our world is
gonna disappear we need to save it
identifiable we can all relate to that
uh and then suddenly halfway through
it's about know I think I belong here
now this is my new home I want to be
here and it's about another person
accepting that and the thing is it's not
like it doesn't set it up at all that
like they are dropping kind of hints in
there but it's kind of done in a way
that doesn't feel natural
um if for example the character wants to
go and be somewhere else feels like in
the previous film this was the character
that wanted to be long was an outcast
and wanted to actually belong somewhere
it finally gets you know to that place
that they want to be at the end where
the other character is okay doing the
same thing you know you know has done
the same thing over and over to it just
just wants to be you know it kind of is
seen as something greater than what eeeh
they've seen it you know get some
recognition so I feel like this should
have been switched the character wants
to go into another realm should probably
be the other one in this it should
probably be switched around uh and I
think that's one of the big problems is
that it doesn't feel like what the
characters are doing kind of goes along
this natural journey that like a
character should be going through they
kind of say while I'm feeling this right
now and then something comes along too
you know to help them with that where it
doesn't feel like they really went
through a long journey that went through
sort of all these different stepping
stones and these sort of twists and
turns that really tie into their
character that would leave into this it
just sort of seems like they said they
want this now and everything in this
just kind of jumps from well now we're
gonna do this thing well now we're gonna
do that thing well now we're interested
this well now we're interested in that
and it kind of goes back and forth
constantly until we go from I don't want
to lose my home to I don't want to lose
my friend who even that's not right it's
I don't want to lose my home to now I
want this home to hey I'm okay with
everything - hey I don't want to lose my
friend and it's kind of these different
elements that are interesting elements
that can be made you know really cool if
they stuck to just one of them but
they're kind of throwing these four
different you know there's four
different puzzle pieces in there and
they don't quite match up and the
internet itself in this you've seen
everywhere this is every sci-fi show
cartoon comic whatever that has said
let's turn the internet into a world
it's all of that and you've seen it
except it's Disney so you can't add the
edge to it like Futurama that's a great
example uh you know I wanted to going to
the internet and and there they are and
it looks exactly like how it does here
like every person that does going into
the Internet looks like and but Futurama
and that's for adults so they can get
away with a lot more adult jokes and
they can really address stuff on the
Internet here when they go by Twitter
what great commentary you could do with
that they don't because it's Disney so
you just see some birds flying around
and you see a bunch of pictures of like
grumpy cat being passed around that
that's their Twitter commentary you know
it YouTube is somewhere in the
background but even when they do their
satire of like YouTube and Facebook and
just cancel show media in general it's
just kind of along the lines of like
well it's just getting a lot of shares
is good and even like even like Ralph
goes and looks at the comments which is
everybody knows you never read the
comments but you can't go with comments
you have to go all the way or you have
to go something beyond Disney you know
with this
you know the movies friggin peachy and
it's like why not you know I don't even
know that I'm just assuming it's peachy
because every G movie is peachy now for
no reason except to get slightly older
kids in there to think it's cool because
you know Disney used to be really good
at saying hey we're G and we don't care
we're doing our own thing but now they
got to put the P in front of there
because I don't know they throw in a
foot size joke like in frozen it's only
has to be PG it's totally dumb but shit
I hope this isn't genome ass but
regardless I'm getting out track um you
are still not allowed to do proper
commentary on the internet without kind
of having a little bit of an edge to it
without taking a little bit of a step
and this is trying to do commentary and
it's it's not even really doing
commentary until the second half and the
second half is where it almost starts to
get interesting but it so nails the
hammer on the head that it's just I
don't know there's no interpretation of
it there's which I don't need like a ton
of interpretation but like a little bit
but this is so spelled out so ok so it
without getting too much into spoilers
uh
the person that wants to go to a
different world wants to leave the
arcade behind you know the other friend
doesn't want that person to go so they
want to corrupt the game they want to
glitch it up they want to ruin the world
which is already a really douchey move
uh you know is somewhere the other
person says this isn't what true friends
do and I'm like yeah it like it's a
really unrelatable thing like it's one
thing to not want a friend leave but you
are just going to this really bizarre
extreme that also seems really out of
character and I just wasn't liking this
character now I mean it's one of those
things where you're kind of watch again
and like well why am I supposed to be
rooting for this person now I don't like
this person doing this I mean this
person seemed really cool it just
doesn't seem like what this person would
do so so they have to go in and
corrupt the system and get again the
subtle commentary um they have to look
for insecurities in the system in the
internet they had to look for
insecurities get it get it like yes you
could have just said problems you could
have just said you could have even said
glitches like tying it back to Penelope
or something but it's like no they said
insecurities and just guess where that's
gonna go just take a wild guess where
that's gonna go with the internet and
program insecurities it goes exactly
where you think it's gonna go so you get
a little bit of creative imagery with
multiplying the insecurities again I
won't give too much away but it results
in another giant monster and again it's
it's one of those detail giant monsters
I'll give it that where when you look
really close yeah you see what makes it
up and it's actually kind of creepy
which I enjoy um and on the one hand
it's like there's no true villain in
this and I I like films that do that
where you know it could be so easy to
put a villain in there but they don't
necessarily do it but at the same time
this is weirdly a movie that could have
used a true villain because the way they
sort of put all the blame and insecurity
on this one character just seemed really
out of nowhere I mean I guess they're
building it up a touch but connected to
the last movie and even the beginning of
this movie like it just doesn't connect
like this is something that would
destroy a friendship and maybe that's
just cynical me talking about it I don't
know but it's one of those things where
I'm like I'm just watching this and it's
like again if this realm exists in this
world exist in someone did this to me
like I I'd be like no that that this
person's out this person is unstable
this I can't be friends with this person
uh so just the idea that we're supposed
to still relate with this relationship
but with this connection after this one
character does something really bad I I
don't I don't follow it I didn't
not make that connection even though I
mean the analogy they're making about
insecurities and not a very vague
analogy but you know the analogy they
make is legit and it is interesting but
if you really want to do this you you
kind of have to go several steps further
I was gonna say all the way but it's
like the Internet is so popular and so
everywhere like I'm like oh okay you you
can kind of you can take one or two
steps back but this is just how no you
can't do it in this Disney kind of fairy
tale realm and it never really dawned on
me going into this that of course you
wouldn't be able to do this you know it
with the brand that Disney has made all
the Disney Princesses are in this of
course you're not going to be able to
dive into the real pros and the real
cons of the Internet
you know and it's something where if
you're watching the the trailer for this
and you're not laughing that much you're
gonna get the same experience with the
movie when I was watching the trailer I
was like man this I me it's wrecking
Ralph's I mean it's gotta be good but
yeah be sure to show a lot of them the
princess is in there like that really
goes on a long time and it got a few
laughs but by manon and nothing that
major that's like the funniest part of
the movie like the stuff with the
princesses at least in that section they
come back again at the end it's kind of
dumb but but the section where Penelope
and she goes and meets the princesses
it's kind of funny like they draw a
connection to Penelope he's trying to
find what she really wants and they say
have you tried looking at water and I
didn't get that and then they said well
no all the princesses you know we
suddenly realize what we want and we
sing a song when we look at water and I
thought about in the Chi list a few
examples I'm like that's a really good
point I never thought about that that
was like actually really really funny
and I don't know if that felt like the
closest to kind of you know poking holes
in the armor kind of showing that yeah
they're Disney but they can you know
sort show their flaws as well and I fell
I feel like we needed more of that with
the internet but you can't because
everyone knows what's on the Internet
everyone knows you know how they go to
the dark web in this of course you're
not going to be able to do as crazy or
insane jokes as you want to do with the
dark net in this so you have to settle
for this really g-rated version of the
dark net which is honestly nothing it
just kind of feels like another version
of the emoji movie you know it honestly
okay I can't see the emoji movie made
better analogies I won't go that far
but it's one of those things where it's
like even like I don't know the color
seemed a little bit more vibrant in the
emoji movie and even though the worlds
look very similar but like I said
everybody that's done a version of the
internet it has done this world it's
always this world the light blue sort of
very flat you know it's just some very
basic shapes sort of blue white you know
these very square objects walking around
square faces or round faces and then
that's it and I just feel like it's the
Internet really so boring they always
talk about how just vast and
never-ending it is and so many
possibilities and how come we always
come back to the exact same designs for
this place this incredible place you
know we're like anything is possible any
great thing any terrible thing at any
anything is possible on the Internet and
we keep coming back to this same setup
um so yeah the big thing too maybe I
could have gone through it a little bit
better if it was funnier it's just not
that funny and it's not even like
they're throwing okay like the emoji
movie well try throwing a lot of jokes
to you ah they don't work and they're
annoying you know that's why something
like that is you see it's really bad uh
we're this it's either not throwing that
many jokes at you or the jokes it does
throw you are not really good but but
they're not groaners either they're just
kind of meh like well yeah that's the
obvious joke you and make there you know
kind of thing um so yeah I don't know
that this is not I feel bad cuz it's
hard to say this is like a bad movie
it's not a movie I see and I'm like oh
my god this is just I can't watch it but
if I saw this like halfway through and
somebody said I could never find out
what happens and the rest of it might be
okay you know I want it to be like no I
have to find out I have to I'm so
invested in their journey and what
they're gonna discover next it's like
I'd really be fine we're in the first
film I couldn't I'd have to know what's
going on and the first film was funny
because it was almost it was almost a
letdown that there weren't as many video
game characters or tie-ins as I wanted
and now compared to this one's a lot
more than you know they give credit for
but it's still one of those where it's
like I kind of put that aside cuz I was
so invested in the story and I was so
invested in these characters and what
they were going through and then this
one like it opens up with when he got
fix-it Felix and I I forget her name the
Jane Lynch character they volunteered to
adopt some of the racers you know all
the racers from sugar rush are little
kids so they volunteered to adopt them
and I'm like this is gonna be fine this
is gonna be really hilarious oh my god
like this couple is already so funny
this tiny little fix a guy in this giant
warrior woman and they're together you
know the total opposites and then you
have now they're gonna have these little
kids and the guy is even warning them
like you know and if kids aren't exactly
what you think it's like oh it'll be
wonderful be just what we need to spice
up our relationship like it's really
setting up that this is gonna be
something really crazy really insane and
really funny
never comes back again until the end
like why even have that there well why
have that set up if you're never gonna
do anything and why build it up if
you're not gonna constantly deliver you
know with the jokes and there's one joke
at the end and it's cute you know but
it's like why have that set up I even
had them in the movie so yeah and the
other characters they discover in this
the only one that got legitimate laugh
out of me is this character named Gort
and he never says a thing he's a
throwaway joke honestly I doubt anyone
else will laugh but he made me laugh
because like it's this guy who's kind of
he's this shady you know guy who sells
ads and you know I make him money
playing video games and stuff and just
whenever he needs something he goes
guard and it's just this little guy
whose eyes look this way you don't even
see most of his face and when he hands
something to someone especially if
they're tall his arm just slowly and
awkwardly reaches out and gives it to
them it just goes totally quiet and it's
so weird it's so uncomfortable I love it
like to me that felt like the Internet
like that's a lot of the Internet but
yeah outside of that like any kind of
commentary outside of the end which
works okay you know you know with the
insecurity thing against very on the
nose you know but it's it's not a bad
lesson but everything else about going
to like buzz tube or buzz face or face
buzz whatever was called it just seems
like stuff that not only have we seen
another places but we've seen in the
emoji movie like that's record Rashtriya
net to steal from the emoji movie you
know it just seems like this has been
done uh so yeah for me this was kind of
a letdown I guess I should have been
that surprised cuz again it is it is
Disney I mean think about this Disney
trying to tackle the Internet like this
is kind of destined to be very bland and
blase but at the same time like they
they tackle the Hunchback of Notre Dom
and I thought that was great
you know there's a lot of things that
didn't work in it but but I thought was
great so maybe I was thinking this would
be something similar like they would be
smart enough to jump through those you
know through those hoops and over those
hurdles you know in their own clever way
their own imaginative Disney way and it
didn't quite work for me and a lot of
that comes down to I just did not
connect with the characters journey and
what they were working towards I worked
with their connection okay for a little
bit you know between Ralph and Penelope
I thought particularly in the first like
dental a Miss they had a really nice
connection a like see him hang out and
going to different games and stuff but
that made it all the more strange when
you see like the break-up like in the
last third and like I said that really
out of character thing that happens in
the first film uh one character has to
do something has to like destroy this
car and everything has so logically
built up to why that character has to do
that and why the character felt like
that this was the right thing to do and
it's one of those things where it's like
yeah I know this part in the movie where
they kind of have to hate each other but
you see how that character got there and
this wasn't you really don't it's just
why don't want to see this person go so
I'm just going to ruin the thing they
love and that's just like no they're too
good of friends for that like they
understand each other more than that and
we had a whole movie showing that so
yeah that just did not that that didn't
that didn't connect with me it just did
not pull me in um but if you're just
looking for a little waste of time to
show your kids that has an okay moral
that I don't know especially with like
kids going on the Internet younger and
younger I mean it might not be a bad
thing to show them it's like yeah it's
fine if you watch the trailer and you
laughed a lot it's those kind of jokes
throughout the whole thing so you'll
probably dig it uh but for me I didn't
laugh much of the trailer and I really
thought the movie was gonna be better I
really thought it was gonna find more
clever ways to work with in there
disadvantages of being a super
family-friendly kid's film and yet
talking about the internet it but it
really didn't but I felt like this film
needed like to more solid rewrites I
like the ideas are there they're good
ideas but they just were not fleshed out
enough so yeah I'm really sorry I feel
awful because
love wreck-it-ralph and i films getting
great reviews like it slightly like
right now that 96% something like that
and it just was not sucking me in and I
really wanted to be sucked in by this
movie because I love these characters I
love the idea than going to the Internet
but I feel like I feel like the Disney
brand was stopping them from really
making some legit good commentary and
the disadvantages they had to work
through just shined all the more in this
and I feel like they really had to make
some sacrifices to the characters that I
really like to sort of tie into this
brand that they have to make a message
that's not a bad message but you have to
sacrifice a little bit of what makes the
characters likeable and relatable I mean
it's okay to not necessarily like a
character but you had to be able to
relate to them I just felt like this was
not relatable so I don't know I I feel
like I'm gonna be the only asshole
I feel like everyone else is gonna love
this movie they're gonna love seeing the
princesses all together and Penelope
with ralphing and having fun and making
poof jokes and stuff but like I don't
know I let me know if I'm the only a
hole here because I feel like I'm gonna
be the only one but maybe I'm not alone
but I feel like I'm going to but
nevertheless if you if you really dug it
and you really enjoyed it enjoy it
there's really nothing like harmful or
bad in it I mean like I said the the
only thing I kind of take a little bit
of issue with it might be a little
dangerous is again sort of like the how
easily the friends kind of forgive each
other where one friend did something
really bad in my opinion like the way
they create this world and the
environment and what this character it
says I think it's really friggin bad and
it's hard to relate with but but maybe
that's just me so yeah guys that's about
it again I'm sorry I couldn't be more
positive on this movie but yeah I can't
help what I feel man so um yeah that's
about it and I will talk to you guys
later
take care
you